ah help the battle between heaven and
hell has waged eternal I'm not sure if
there's a worse way to start your movie
than with narration and a fake bird all
the docks blow it needs now it's a great
soldier just one great soldier it's like
the Bad News Bears for demons sure
everyone on the team sucks but if you
can get one person on that team that's
good it will turn them into a force just
ask the Los Angeles Angels you know the
one located in generics Ville on Main
Street close to the unspecific ocean
also though this is supposedly a
military airbase in Hong Kong but this
is clearly a small commercial jet being
operated by American Eagle which is a
subsidiary of American Airlines also
American airline this guy leads with a
kick then proceeds to blow away the
entire control room in a hail of bullets
and editing I would have led with the
gun but when will you ever get to use
that sweet move again right how is the
airport not on super lockdown after all
the machine gunfire in the tower why are
the deep planing anyone right now pretty
effective missile I will admit but is
there any reason you had the ninja break
into air traffic control and fire the
missile from there I get that there was
proximity and a height advantage and
shooting from here but you had night
vision an Xbox controller gadget thinks
and here in Hong Kong
the city with the most skyscrapers per
square mile than any other on earth you
couldn't find an easier place to find
this missile from brought to you by the
studio that would somehow be able to
fund a whole Lord of the Rings trilogy
this movie does the ultra cheap route
and doesn't even bother to blow up a
real airplane fire effects borrowed from
Mortal Kombat or borrow what do you come
up with something that's cheesy and lame
thinks it's actually edgy as an old for
cool oh yeah introduction after effects
it's always a welcome sight when the
actor playing the title character isn't
the first name you see and it's an even
better sight when that first actor's
name is John Leguizamo yep the Martin
Sheen because despite his established
greatness he was still several months
shy of being offered the West Wing and
everyone's got bills yeah also the fire
tornado metal opening credits of hate
made me throw up three times but also is
the new name of my band so this entire
credits sequence music and all is like
reliving the 90s all over again this is
what Bill Clinton dreams but dust
brothers masturbate to this credit
sequence no not together that would be
the Chemical Brothers
it's like this movie saw the opening
credits for seven two years earlier and
decided to go for the middle school
version of that also holy balls seven
percent of this entire movie is this
long opening fire tornado credits hey
Pew mark a dot Z dot dip a not for the
movie but for having to middle initials
the hell is that about dog it's not the
problem I don't doubt that desperate man
would do anything to attain wealth and
power and would sell their souls for it
I just don't think they believe a
cigarette smoking clown demon could
provide it they tried to 60 minutes
shadow this guy but it's clearly a
member of the Insane Clown Posse also
why is this asshole in shadows how do
you properly light a room so that
Satan's henchmen can be properly cloaked
during a conversation what's the point
anyway I guess they asked John Leguizamo
to do his best penguin from Batman
Returns voice or else this is just
highway robbery here were you just
talking about this guy earlier why not
bring this up then you might be
wondering why does it matter but they
spent this whole scene talking about
building a weapon that Martin Sheen
already knew we had to build and this is
a PS why do you want him okay so how do
you want it not seeing how that's
funnier and it's actually less likely to
get me the answer I was looking for with
the original question you dick this
headline should read USA Today
completely abuses the increased kerning
function on this double-decker front
page headline also I capitalized all the
words in this headline except blow up
also also again I remind you that was an
American Eagle jet not a British
airliner but whatever USA Today everyone
knows your reputation has been shot
since that you've jailed erroneous
headline bull and back to the future to
also times 3-under this white dudes
picture there's a caption about Michael
Jordan and under this white woman's
picture there's a caption about Will
Smith so maybe get out happened earlier
when we thought this magic there's been
lurking around for a while now though
this is the first time he's glowed
bright green but my point is this guy
the airport Killzone was supposed to be
clear of civilians I know we just got
news about the civilians and he's mad
about it but didn't he see the civilians
with his high-tech headgear earlier or
does his headgear only detect bad guys
this she's got a gun in her underwear
Sean is all about titillating you and
has nothing to do with the story that
sees this guy soon becoming an
all-powerful hell agent
what the fuck is this why does he have
an ashtray in his pet scorpion bowl it's
like how can we make the Martin Sheen
characters seem more evil I know let's
show that he has pet scorpions and he
puts out cigarettes in an ashtray
located inside the bowl this guy I give
zero fucks about scorpion stings and
lung cancer casual tarantula fun come on
son this is top priority a little on the
nose but honestly I'd rather watch more
on the nose scorpion attack imagery than
most of the plot I've seen of this thing
so far you know we've been awesome
seeing how Simmons all by himself
infiltrated this top-secret North Korean
weapons facility without anyone seeing
him I really don't think there was
enough time for president bartlet and
julie cooper-nichol to get off the boat
they just casually walked out while the
damn thing exploded and it's not like
they had Wonder Woman's invisible jet
waiting to take them out of here before
this place blew yeah you know for
someone that was ambushed burned to
death and woke up in the rainy worst
part of the city from Blade Runner this
guy sure he's kind of an asshole he sets
out to reclaim his humanity okay sure
but he saw his reflection in the water
he knows his face looks like an avocado
had sex with an older more disgusting
avocado doesn't he know his lady is not
only not going to recognize him but also
who likely to call the cops and probably
a priest at least make the phone call
the thing tries to make an Fantastic
Four were before scaring your kids and
of course Toto can still smell his old
master years later and through the layer
of burned reincarnated skin Wanda and
Terry end up hiring the clown makes
hooker jokes drinks smokes and has
jagged teeth for this birthday party are
they blinded to this because of some
sort of spell or something Oh imagine
being the guy that did the CGI on the
fart for the scene like would you ever
even tell anyone also this front reminds
me since will never send this saying
year's John Leguizamo classic the pest
can I just go ahead and transfer 50 sins
from that movie to the scene right here
it's a bit of a complicated sin
retirement account math and it's rarely
invoked but I feel like this scene
deserves it okay skidmark
sometimes sin retirement accounts
compound in Chris Daly and that's why
this is getting an additional 100 55
cents
going to add 478 more for the visuals
and 1763 more sins for this movie being
a dick good God if I were Satan I would
be embarrassed at this CGI hell escape
he calls home call a fucking decorator
or Stan Winston and get this cleaned up
by army you can see one again so in this
flashback al is reminded of his deal
with malbolge ax but why does this
process make him forget that the first
place is it so violator has something to
do it's hard to believe that hell and
over millions of years hasn't perfected
this a way win only killed him because
the clown told him to and the clown
works for you and your first command is
to have him kill win you could have had
win killed in any number of other ways
he's thinking is your guardian angel as
long as we don't have to think of you as
Luigi ever ever again
he died a patriot do you want to know
what year he died you because of course
there's a small group of poser Satanists
doing some rituals here tonight as I'm
sure there are and every cemetery around
the world every night what what no I've
got to know what is this place that I
have found what is roll credits people
can still die how do you call it when
the fart clown spits out the rules of
the film's universe instead of normal
dialogue clowns position John Leguizamo
position so does this locket with Wallis
pictures supposed to give him some sort
of extra motivation or power it's
literally the only reason why he dug up
his own grave so my answer would be yes
even though I don't understand why he
needs it and it's stupid
I mean even Tron is pissed off at these
special effects this free stuff's gonna
come in handy when I get my hands on way
glad you could remind yourself and us if
that fact my IQ dropped about a hundred
points after just 30 minutes of this
movie so I did not understand that until
you said so I am Kali Oscar oh that's
all you need to know from now it would
be devastating to the movies runtime if
I told you anything more he pushes this
guy to the left then goes around him on
the right only to turn left why not just
not push the guy at all and go left
sometimes putting words on your screen
to tell us where we are it's actually
more confusing than saying nothing at
North Korean biochemical operation
really paid off that one from five years
ago it just happens to coincide with our
hero's murder weird that you're exposing
about that just after he's come back to
Earth from Hell to kill you did the
screenwriter give you a heads up
now we
weapons in place to disperse heat-16
over half of this got for second clothes
so why does your virus simulation show
the entire world being infected if the
simulation is accurate you better be in
some sort of underground bunker when
this hits flappy cape jump then dragging
two victims spoopy spent so much on
terrible bright-green farts CGI it
couldn't afford to film actual action
scenes that might have been fun to watch
also the clown left and said he'd return
when spawns armor had hardened so he
immediately attacks a place with soft
armor no Joe just had a birthday didn't
she his terrible facial hair part of the
uniform for this place Sheen looks like
he's auditioning for West Bentleys
Hunger Games role and DB's goatee is
getting harassing phone calls from a
dozen better film goatees this is the
headquarters of the elite military
outfit he used to work for and that had
him killed and you're telling me he
scaled the building a few stories to
this point and no one saw nor stopped
him what year was it cameras exist in
this universe right how much did these
spawn Cape CGI transitions cost you how
much better would this movie be if you'd
spent all that money on hiring a better
writer yep
also no one is shooting his ass yet you
sent me to college Jason movie
subliminally advertises Jason goes to
hell four years after it came out
[Music]
no one is still shooting his ass yet you
know about cyan the greenish bluish
color yes I'm aware of it do you know
about magenta she shoots guns at the
dead guy from hell and he runs to hide
from them even though I don't think
bullets will matter much and the battle
spawn has ahead of him didn't the clown
tell him that he could only die by
getting his head chopped off what good
is I'm gonna do I mean unless you have
that vagina dentata think oh you meant
killing luckily I wore my bitings go
belt which specifically protects me from
getting kicked in the balls you know I
could have used a belt like this during
six through eleventh grade where you're
going every day's New York City Fashion
Week you don't have the guts what what
is it about Al's character that makes
you think he doesn't have the guts to
kill people dude is known for killing
fools wasn't his mission to kill Jason
win I'd say he totally failed that
mission my favorite part about the wrong
dead guy turned hell warrior superhero
movie is the scene where he done all the
shooting with the machine guns in both
hands that's exactly how I would have
pictured hell demons fighting actually
so spawn disappears in an act of
self-preservation that he doesn't even
appear to control but then he reappears
in the same spot for absolutely no
reason
heaping piles of bull on the out
this is like that Daniel Craig weapon in
Cowboys and Aliens I mean getting
magnets man now that he's on the run
from all the bullets where the because
that goddamn magical cloak even as a
reflex it should be working
it'll be seated during the exciting cops
fruitlessly shoot at spawn while he
slowly walks on the ledge scene even as
someone who was just demanding more
cloak action what the fuck was that I
don't care what kind of intricate
labyrinths the paramedics and
firefighters have created with their
cars there cannot be a private place for
the violator and Jason to have a
conversation here not only is she his
ex-girlfriend she's also actively
reporting and lecturing on the chemical
abuses that occurred because he went on
that mission that killed him
coincidences this strong only happened
in comics and comic based movies the
world
introspection look.we excitement she
brought her daughter and her dog and the
dogs tennis ball to her super important
lecture movie should never have time for
this giving orders to win way before
spawn was even spawn true or false did
you or did you not overly complicate
this from playing man whose past dog
kicking we do totally so spaz I spend
one second looking for him when he can
walk home what's the worst that could
happen
spawns decision to go back to the alley
he arrived in coincides perfectly with
this hateful homeless guy beating the
kid that one time offered spawn a soda
man along circular storytelling it's the
best we had a long circular storytelling
it's the best that's bad another hero
has a heart of gold cliche even though
this hero was a hell demon with almost
no redeeming qualities as per your
orders director win if your vital signs
flatline for any reason the device will
uplink and detonate the heat-16 bombs no
one would dare kill you so how do you
spread the word about that do you go on
TV explain your evil plan and say don't
kill me my heart has hooked up to all
the bombs or do people just know within
5 seconds of meeting you that you're
probably the type of guy that hooks up
detonators to its heart
it's time the Lightning told me so I'm
gonna cut 50 pieces and Mail you Tavi
steak oh no the mailing is the worst
part but down by dog movie inspires the
entire John wick franchise if you are
this powerful all along why did you ever
waste time on that clown bull dog kick
hey seriously with a demon this powerful
why does malbolge you even need spawn to
lead his army where is cape really spawn
movie Jesus pose really really I don't
mean to invoke the pest more than it
needs to be but how did John Leguizamo
survive in 1997 playing these two
characters this is some serious view up
for life type of to inhabit your spawn
but that doesn't mean you have to be
what they want something tells me you're
about to dump some exposition you needed
to dump half an hour ago Al Simmons knew
that violence only makes for more pain
and suffering no matter which side gives
the orders he tried to leave off killing
give himself a second chance
we saw none of these character traits in
alla before he died sure he was upset
about killing the innocent civilians but
he didn't have any qualms about killing
in general your old life is gone except
that things someone said to Martin Sheen
to get him to sign on to this film
somehow made in the script spawn keeps
his weapons cash in an easily accessible
unlocked area where any homeless dude
could find it and steal it
you've been using your armor only by
reflex you must learn to control it if
only I could have run into you sooner we
could have figured out this whole thing
to get oh we did meet sooner you said I
was on a need-to-know basis no hero just
begins to learn something but becomes an
instant expert in seconds cliche take
care of your powers when you drain them
you'd I won't be needing these
I know discount obi-wan told spawn that
the guns were useless but he didn't seem
to learn anything about how he was going
to win without killing people he learned
how to get horny and he learned stuff
about his chains but that was about it
clown he's so full of great pop-culture
references including movies starring one
of his co-stars but over the years how
has this guy watched all these movies
does he go to movie theaters or rent
stuff at Blockbuster to pass the time
when he's not middle Manning he stands
up from the crash of the spawn cycle to
face the imminent attack of the klom
truck and I hate myself for typing any
of that movie steals the Bruce Willis
from die hard to reading secure files
this 1997 computer is so helpful giving
him audio explanations of what's
happening at all times
man this movie this motherfucker is the
most annoying clown since Pennywise went
through a slam poetry phase what would
happen if violator just killed Jason
right now I realized that means that
they've broken their bargain but really
one of the consequences a blow for this
movie to actually explain that you join
Hills Army or she dies I thought he
already agreed to join in lead Hills
army back when he first went on dead did
I miss read that scene movie
subliminally advertises Jason goes to
hell four years after it came out you
would get a soul and kickstart the
Apocalypse Now or kickstart the West
Wing or kickstart the wall street or
kickstart the badlands is this guy I've
been doing this whole time if he can
help then why hasn't he been helping
movie combines darkness with horrible
CGI and editing to give us this
climactic battle this is the kind of
Jewish that newline cranked out back
then
it's Mortal Kombat's fault for being
halfway decent but they turned out this
stuff with no regret it is physically
painful to watch this movie no one
thought this was terrible enough to cut
or improve before the movie came out if
you could quantify the amount of
whatever this movie's manufactured you
could weaponize it and kill millions of
people with indifference I mean big
fighter had better graphics than this it
cannot be stressed enough this is worth
another 10,000 sins I think
well apparently spawn can do that it's
sort of an accidental ex machina oh and
he knows how to fly too he learned some
real intricate in the last minute of
this battle cyan screams but whatever
she's screaming about doesn't appear
until well after she yells that's kind
of both right in addition to naming your
kids cyan don't know why violator is
still alive and don't care there were
entirely too many fireplace shenanigans
taking place in this movie I'm halfway
expecting Sirius Black to show up and
warn Harry about some danger but for
someone to use the flu network to go to
the Quidditch Cup for the past five
years I unwittingly participated in
Jason Wynn's illegal manipulation of the
asic do you need a fucking lawyer right
now you don't start spilling all your in
front of the house at a crime scene
spawn has stopped now bulges plans to
destroy the earth did this demon really
depend on one asshole to carry out his
plan I thought a bunch of other people
in the world were banking on selling
their souls for wealth and power but the
only guy who could help him with his
plan was Martin Sheen
you know where you love her and cannot
live without her
[Music]
I wanted to ask you a couple of
questions while I had you here I'm
interested in selling my youngest
daughter into slavery as sanctioned in
exodus 21:7 she's a Georgetown sophomore
speaks fluent Italian always cleared the
table when it was her turn what would a
good price for her be take out US
tariffs for $100 it takes a steady hand
because if you touch the side goodbye
close I have been falling for 30 minutes
you look like Freddy Krueger face
topographical map of Utah this is even
more painful than it looks
you see you've been using your armor
only by reflex you must learn to control
it
it has trillions of neural connections
once again things that could have been
brought to my attention yesterday
present me
120 precursor orbs for each Power Cell I
can do